this framework decision into National
Law this is important to ensure that all
Au citizens across the union have the
same rights and can fully exercise them
the commission launch 13 infringement
procedures relating to gaps in
transposition and since October 2020 10
member states have taken action to
change their
legislation yet the criminalization of a
speech across the European Union remains
fragmented and the framework decision
only covers racist and xenophobic
grounds in December 2021 the commission
adopted a proposal for a council
decision to include head speech and head
crime in the list of au crimes in
article 83 of the treaty on the
functioning of the European
Union if the decision is adopted the
commission would be able to propose a
common approach to the criminalization
of Aid speech and Aid crime and showing
a consistent protection of all victims
of such acts across the European Union
while the Cil had not yet reached the
needed
unanimity the recent resurgence of head
speech and head crime underlines the
imperative for Rapid adoption of um this
Council
decision we welcome the strong support
and the commitment of the open
Parliament for this initiative we
notably welcome the adoption of your
report on this file I would like to
thank in particular the libe committee
and their reporter M pagazo Tunda for
their
commitment our recent joint
communication also focuses on the need
to respond to the threats of head speech
online since
2016 we have a code of conduct in place
which aims to keep platforms accountable
for curbing head speech on their
services this code has been a success
according to the data we collect in our
yearly monitoring exercise content
moderation has significantly improved
although a slight slow on has been noted
recently but the digital landscape has
evolved in the last years in particular
after the entry into force of the
Digital Services act in November 2022
the DSA requires all online platforms to
have in place notice and act action
systems to allow for us user reports on
illegal content including head
speech codes of conduct will continue to
be an important tool under the DSA in
particular as part of the platform
response to systemic risks this is why
we are advancing fast towards the
adoption of a revised code of conduct
the main objective of the revision
is to improve its preventive
capability and help anticipate Rising
threats of head speech before they go
viral I'm confident that the
negotiations will be concluded soon and
that the new code will also be granted
at the status of a DSA code of conduct
or December communication also recalls
the importance of advancing on tackling
anti-Semitism by
intensifying the implementation of the
2021 till 2030 Au strategy on combating
anti-Semitism and fostering Jewish life
the Au anti-racism action plan 2020 till
2025 as well as of the order equality
strategies after the attack by hamus
against Israel of the seventh of October
and the war that ured anti-semitic
incidents have spiked both online and
offline today many European Jews are
again living in fear and some even feel
obliged to hide their
identity at the same time we have seen
some increase in anti-muslims hatred and
indeed a General rise in hate speech
notably
online combating racism and
discrimination countering negative
stereotypes and ensuring equality in
societies through positive action
continues to be
Central we are step stepping up our
efforts to fight hatred in all its forms
by reinforcing action across a variety
of policies
including security digital education
culture and
Sport
finally the J communication provides
that the commission's coordinators on
combating anti-Semitism anti-muslim
hatred and on combating racism will be
upgraded to envoys with a view to
maximizing the potential of au policies
to combat hatred so I thank you for your
commit commment to fight with us against
all those form of head speech and head
crime and I will be pleased to listen to
your remarks and your proposal during
this debate thank
you thank you very much uh commission
commissioner and now it's a pleasure to
give the floor to the chair of the
committee on women's rights and gender
equality Robert Pon the floor
please dear president dear commissioner
de colleagues hate speech and height
crimes are our shared European problems
it is clear that with internet and
social media hate does not stop at any
borders it becomes widespread it becomes
our European problem this is why we call
again on the council to take the
decision to add hate speech and hate
crimes to the least of Euro crimes I'm
disappointed that this seat today is
empty what what is more we need to
ensure that sexist and gender-based hate
speech will be explicitly defined in the
legislation that will follow today 52%
of women and girls have experienced
online crime including hate speech and
sexual harassment women and minorities
are targeted in the real world and
online by individuals and as well as by
organized well organized far right and
anti-gender movements who work to
undermine our European values tolerance
and respect for one and another are
principles that all member states share
with each other and therefore tackling
hate crimes should be our shared common
responsibility thank you very
much thank you very much uh and now uh
for the EP magdalina adamovic please
commissioner chair AIT did not drop out
of the blue sky uh Holocaust did not
start with gas Chambers uh genocide did
not start out of the out of the blue it
did not start with
matchetts uh children's uh suicide does
not start with Bridges or ropes the
murder of my husband the president of G
not start with the with a knife the evil
evil starts with the word tragedies of
individual persons and the greatest
crime against
humanity they all start from
dehumanization uh and uh calling to hate
instigation to hate when will we finally
understand that it is words words that
kill and that the words that kill do not
fall under the the freedom of speech it
we must not treat as freedom of speech
Things That Kill when will we finally
understand that call to hate kills also
democracy and that the hate speech is
the favorite tool of anti- Democrats in
each and every member state it is a tool
for those also who want to uh threaten
our democracy from outside Russia has
built a huge Machinery to do that to
kill the European value Putin is ruining
our European house using weapons Rockets
um but we have long enable allowed him
to do that by hate speech right now we
need to spend huge amounts of money in
order to guard ourselves against his
Rockets but we still cannot effectively
guard ourselves and protect ourselves
against his troll Farms these words that
call for hate and call for murder are a
tool for murder and they should be
treated as such this is why I in I
invite I appeal to the member states to
unblock the negotiations in the council
we need to include in such crime hate
crime and height speech uh we need to
put them on the list of crime that is
regulated in the
treaties uh and now for the sndd group
vice president Katrina p
thank you very much president
commissioner hate crime is terrible for
the victim but is also a threat for all
peaceful societies right now in Germany
we're experiencing the afd Neo-Nazi
deportation order that has been issued
by them for individuals who are not
German uh that these individuals be
deported in Italy we have Neo fascists
which are resuscitating the fascist
ideology of the
1930s survivors of from the Holocaust
said just a couple of months ago things
started this way then as well so uh
critics and those that think differently
and those who would have liked to think
differently those who all fear uh they
are afraid now indeed to express
themselves so we have to protect all
individuals which are on out on the
streets uh fighting for human rights for
democracy we have to protect women as
well women which have fallen victim
online uh we must protect Jews men and
women from the unfortunately increasing
anti-Semitism um Muslims from
islamophobia we have to protect those
who have fallen victim to transphobia as
well as well individuals with
disabilities as well have to be
protected people who have another
another skin color who frequently fall
victim so all individuals uh must be
protected from hate crimes hate speech
and we have to create a space where
there's
trust and where individuals who commit
these crimes will be
prosecuted uh I think unfortunately
unfortunately some governments are
protecting these individuals or groups
they feel that they are not responsible
for for protecting their populations
from these types of crimes and these
types of
criminals thus I think it's important
for us to have a European system of
protection against hate crimes we need a
decision of the council right now and
this is the time to act thank you thank
you very much and now for the Renu group
Samir rafaa
please we live in a world where we
cannot Escape digital communication and
information a world where social media
is part of our daily lives and this is
where things get complicated the spread
of hate on the Internet is a thre that
is ever so real and is directly
connected to hate speech and hate crime
in the physical world the deliberate
dissemination of misinformation and
hateful content reaches us all and feeds
into very dangerous narratives and
so-called ideologies fellow politicians
especially women but also women of color
are afraid to run for a public office
because the public scrutiny is becoming
unbearable they are subject to hate
speech in a form that is unprecedented
in its cruelty its exp explicitness and
its damaging nature and we have to be
more Vigilant and more prepared than
ever to fight the spreading of this hate
inciting content to fight and report and
acknowledge hate crime crimes for what
they are and punish them accordingly to
show the victims that they are not alone
we have the tools we have the values and
we have the technology in our Union to
win the fight against but also with the
big Tech because they play an important
role and show them that we the European
Union are the champions of democratic
values and human rights thank you thank
you very much uh our next speaker for
the group of the greens is Alis ba
please
than thank you
president hate threats and the fear of
violence is something that many of my
friends in the lgbtqi community have to
deal with on a daily basis and this has
become worse violence against members of
the lgbtqi community in Europe has
become more serious uh than in the past
10 years and we are losing the f
against hatred when I say we I mean
those of us who do everything in our
power to make this world a world where
people are allowed to be who they are
love who they want and live in Freedom
and in safety because there are other
politicians in this house and in our
member states who do not belong within
this category of we they ferment this
hate and they among the ruling class in
Sweden when politicians differentiate
between different categories of
people and ferment this hatred that
affects
others more hate is
born hate crimes and hate-based
propaganda must be criminalized across
the EU we must not forget though that a
punishment is uh punishment for Crime
already committed if we really want to
make a difference and if we really want
to win this fight against hate then we
need to do more than that and that
starts with us those of us who are in
political positions of power thank you
thank you very much uh and now alexand
VRA for the E
Group
excuse me sorry uh I'm sorry to
interrupt you I just uh was told there
is no English interpretation so uh if
you could be so kind to start again but
first first we have to check if it
works it seems to work right now so
sorry for interrupting you and please
again we start from the beginning
please excuse me sorry I mean it's
really something I don't like
still not working so a little break
until we have uh the
interpretation so German is working
perfectly I could invite everybody to
choose this uh beautiful language but I
think we also have to make sure if
English is is uh uh
guaranteed normally I would speak in
English I want to
say yeah
so
so I'm sorry I hope this will be the
last time you have to start so I invite
you to uh speak again and I hope the
English interpretation uh works right
now properly so
please so as I was saying that's a key
value and we very much reject the idea
this can be limited moreover it's worth
pointing
out that this whole question is often
something put forward from the dogmatic
left the whole question of criticism of
migration policy with the fear that you
might be accused of promoting hate this
means we find ourselves in a terrible
situation where in European C capitals
there are hundreds of thousands of
people demonstrating with terrorist
Flags talking about massacres targeted
at
Jews so what we're trying to do now is
to ensure that these efforts be
underpinned by
law but that's a strange way of solving
the
problems in life we have to be able to
willing to accept criticism even if it's
wrong every
state has
the tools it needs to tackle this
problem harmonization the European level
is not
necessary I myself come from an atheist
country in
Europe but I would not find it
acceptable that politicians be hauled
before courts because they promote
religion for example Dan
please your struggle against hate speech
in actual fact is a different struggle
in Disguise you're seeking to protect
protect an ultra minority ideology
trying to remove any kind of debate any
kind of public discussion I mean if I
were to say for instance I don't want
miners to receive hormonal treatment or
other medical treatment that's not hate
speech against transgender persons it is
a declaration of love for children if I
fight against excessive migration into
my country our continent if I speak
about the consequences of your awful
migration pact I'm not moved by hatred
I'm moved by love for my
country love for our continent I don't
think you're really in a democratic
discussion anymore you're sort of in the
sphere of theocracy you don't want
political debate you want some kind of
Inquisition you're not on on the side of
reason you're on a quasi religious
discourse here and you are actually
moving us into Dark Times renewed dark
times so please let's open up the debate
let's not stifle free debate thank
you uh Claire Daly uh is our next
speaker uh for the left
group thank you sh president in the past
few months we've seen Palestinian
solidarity decried as hate speech we've
seen claims of anti-Semitism being used
to downplay the slaughter of innocence
in Gaza and to cover up for the
legitimate criticism of Zionism and with
all of this rage in in the background
the EU decides to stomp onto the scene
with plans to criminalize hate speech
and the problem with that is do we trust
the EU to Define hate speech and do we
trust them to ensure that it won't be
used to criminalize legis legitimate
political speech and action and I have
to say I don't this has all the
Hallmarks of another clumsy and
counterproductive neoliberal response to
a social problem it's cheaper to
criminalize hate speech than to fund and
focus on the strategies that might
Foster tolerance it's a gimmick to allow
politicians to pretend to care about
minorities and racism and so on while
doing nothing to protect them doing
nothing to address the structural issues
that lead to hate intolerance in the
first place structural issues which
include Centrist politicians dog
whistling about migration so for me I
think once again I don't trust V allance
commission to police my
speech uh our next speaker is Clara
ponsati ools
please thank you
president any height speech V ation risk
criminalizing those minorities or
residents that seeks to protect and so
it risk becoming a tool to protect the
dominant groups of
society the elaboration of this report
I'm afraid is a prime example of this BR
has entrusted the party
fanos to prepare this report it's the
party that was born to suppress Catalan
identity and language a Shen of
party that shamefully was admitted into
the Liberals in exchange for a handful
of votes they specialize in dehumanizing
opponents including me and my colleagues
they specialize in
laware it's a party that will soon die
suffocated in its own
hate look at who they consulted to write
this report for example impulso theano a
satellite Proto fascist organization
responsible for the removal of the
Catalan president for exhibiting a
banner in support of Human Rights how
can we hope that this report will help
to will help to strike a fair balance
between protection of vulnerable groups
and freedom of expression well in the
present conditions we cannot thank you
very
much uh thank you very much uh before I
give the floor to Lucas Mandel I would
really kindly like to invite all
speakers in this debate to be
disciplined concerning the time we have
a very long list of speakers and uh I
just let a little bit longer speak those
representing the political parties so
please be disciplined and stick to the
time sorry you're the first one to whom
to apply but uh you have the floor Mr
Man thank you very much Madame President
commissioner colleagues
an Vol
bfer he said that the modern State lives
from principles it can't achieve and
what people um Ordinary People live from
is to be able to speak uh freely and if
we have hate speech in our society um
people are afraid of saying freely what
they think and they defending this
freedom of thought means um acting
against hacked hate speech it's uh
poison in our societies from politics
but people who don't think they're
political but who are active on social
media and bring the poison into our
societies last this week I had a a guest
Daniel low in the uh European Parliament
he was behind the yes we care campaign
uh representing citizens who want to
deal with each other uh respectfully and
we defend them when we act against uh
hate spe speech and this poison in our
society uh our next speaker is Helen
friton please
Helen thank you very much Madame
President my girlfriend was punched in
the face I myself was kicked down to the
ground and then the people who did this
run away just as quickly I'm quoting
here a young woman together with her
girlfriend they were exposed to hate
crime in
Sweden these are serious crimes and they
have devastating consequences for the
individuals concerned for society as a
whole and for democracy across the board
in Europe we have strong extremist
forces which are using precisely this
hatred threats in order to silence
others and in order to dismantle
democracy we've seen this on the
internet we see it on our streets on our
squares and we see it in this house hate
and hate propaganda is something we must
fight against and that is why I welcome
this fight against these divisive forces
and under all circumstances we should
stand up for human rights democracy and
coexistence thank you uh and I give the
floor to cathaline
T hanging you is too kind you should be
skinned alive
why can't she just be shot she's just a
lying politician it's a shame that a
horny Russian hasn't raped you yet so
colleagues these are actual comments
from my social media and I'm quite sure
that all of my fale female colleagues no
matter if they sit on the left side or
the right side of this uh Parliament or
in the center you are familiar with
statements like this I am not here to
complain I have to say that I am in a
privileged position I have chosen a
career in the public eye I have the
resources to see seek help and a
platform to speak out but I think about
all the women who do not those who
suffer in silence those who endure
hatred violence and harassment often in
their home without support or voice and
when certain member states such as
Hungary block progress on hate crime
legislation these are the women they are
failing because there is a war on women
by these uh leaders these are the
leaders who claim that the fight against
gender based violence is liberal
hysteria they claim that the istan
convention is against their values as if
violence could ever be a
so I demand the Belgian presidency to
take action they have to protect the
women EU rules on the safety of women
and all citizens should not include opt
out this is not optional we need binding
rules not just empty words right now
thank you very much thank you very much
uh I will give the floor to Kim fpar
please dear colleagues the freedom of
speech doesn't mean the fre freedom to
spread hate but increasingly the lgbtiq
plus Community people of color migrants
and other minorities encounter hate
speech especially online and this hate
is fueled by the farite groups and
Amplified by social media algorithms and
the purpose of this online hate is clear
they want to silence us and turn
minorities into
scapegoats and we know that online hate
does not stay online we see a stark RIS
in violence against the lgbtiq plus
community with recent years being the
most violent in ages and this is a
danger both to the safety of individuals
and to our democracies Europe has to
send a clear signal to society and to
online platforms there is no place for
hate speech and hate crimes in the EU so
to the council act now add hate speech
and hate crimes to the list of EU crimes
make sure everyone can feel safe
everywhere in Europe and act against the
amplification of hate and disinformation
by social media's algorithms thank
you thank you very much uh oh and next
speaker on the list is Patrick
Yaki thank you Madame President
commissioner given
this draft um to fight hate you said
that if
you uh
if the LGBT people or if
a a migrant has committed a crime he can
be uh locked
up it's about
fighting fre religious freedom too
expressing your religion and say that
there are two uh biological genders that
would also be a
crime and you putting that dressing that
up in in nice
words
you
know what rep repressive tolerance means
this is a tolerance
against the from the right from the left
it's terrorizing it's not a
freedom you don't tolerate
Freedom we can't uh accept this proposal
from uh Madame
AB Madame
adamovic
please can you say me tell me straight
in the eyes can can you look my uh
daughter in the eyes can you talk about
hate of
all
uh we've had to go through all these uh
words and these hate words re relayed by
public
television could you say something on
that question please
sir Madam of
course I regret
fully what your husband has gone through
and your family have gone through but
you see that the public
media the situation has been reversed
it's the media
Who U diffuse hate against us it's your
uh supporters who want to assassinate my
family and are locking up their
opponents
today the question today is
this do you think
that the hate against uh you is bad but
but but against us hate can be
propagated I don't
think the hate can't limit freedom of
expression everybody really to respect
uh exactly what we are debating right
now not to use too harsh
words Sylvia sardone is our next
speaker
you want to be big brothers you want to
instigate thought crime so as to limit
freedom of speech and expression you
want to take over the powers of member
states so as to use new rules to attack
anybody who's against your
ideology we are obviously in favor of
trying to tackle genuine hate crime and
discrimination we are against fighting
and bullying in schools and bullying
online these are real risks which
threaten the well-being of young
people however using the excuse of
preventing crimes you now want to start
policing the web and social
media so as to remove posts and news
from certain parts of the political
Spectrum using the digital service act
act you have already made it clear that
you can talk about Rebel voices which
aren't in line with the left and those
voices must of course be silenced you
want to promote a model where the ideas
and thoughts of our people can be
silenced by simply labeling face news
fake
news I would like to know what types of
speech really would be characterized as
hate what are the areas where you can
say things which aren't part of the
general convention the mainstream once
again Brussels is trying to import the
Chinese model here in Europe uh thank
you our next speaker is Elena cont
please thank you
chair
commissioner I would like uh to speak to
the presidency of theil that is not here
today and this is
unacceptable during these past few years
we have seen hate speech uh increase at
a worryingly degree at a woring degree
in the EU and the inter and we're
talking about vulnerable groups uh
persons with disabilities and lgbti
persons we have asked from the European
Parliament a lot of times from the
council to extend the list of EU crimes
so as to include hate speech and hate
crimes we are to have minimum rules for
the definition of these crimes as well
as their punishment this is something
that the commission has also prop
proposed it's been two years now in this
way we will have a
uniform uh actions against these crimes
so we would like to call the council to
move forward immediately thank you very
much thank you very much uh and I give
the floor to Francesca
Donato gra pres thank you madam
president their proposal to extend the
list of crossboard crimes to to include
incitement to hate is simply not
realistic as well as being incompat
incompatible with the principles of law
when it comes to principles such as
proportionality and
efficiency any new law or regulation
must describe in a very precise way
exactly what times of speech would
exactly would be classified as health
speech so as to avoid that anybody
saying anybody can be characterized as
hate lots of people in the European
Parliament for example with this open
definition could be accused of uh hate
speech for criticizing other politicians
or heads of
States but freedom of speech freedom of
expression is a fundamental right in the
European Union its expression cannot be
limited by generic standards and Norms
which could cover anything which might
create negative
sentiments moreover we canot accept any
such procedure which should involve
prosecutors being instigated to try to
characterize these as
crimes women and other people in in
democracy will be characterized as using
hate speech this is being used to cancel
negative ideas in state and that kind of
idea has been impossible ever since
human beings were first first came
about thank you very much for the floor
dear ladies and gentlemen as a member of
the Roma Community I have been the
target of hate for a long time so I know
what I'm talking about and while the
number of hate speech and hate crimes
has been increasing in recent years the
fight against these crimes is stagnating
and today today we are at a historical
Crossroads because the spread of hatred
has already been accepted by a large
part of the society today fascists and
extremists who spread hatred are uh are
in Democratic parliaments of several
countries including Slovakia and uh
ladies and gentlemen we have been
overlooking for some time already they
are abusing democracy and freedom of
speech and we only start dealing with
these hate crimes when something bad
happens when somebody loses their life
because of being different so colleagues
how many people do we do have need to
die before we start start fighting
against hate because those who spread
hate are the same criminals as those who
spread terrorism and I'm asking all
competent people please start punishing
those who act uh who who act like they
are superhumans and protect those who
are the victims of hate
attacks thank you very much I give the
floor now toen Fernando Lopez agil
please thank you very much Madam
president commissioner
reinders I think that the European
Parliament has been clear in supporting
the initiative taken by the commission
to really put an end to these
forms of hate speech and hate crimes no
discrimination based on race or any
other grounds sexual orientation age Etc
physical ability all vulnerable groups
should be protected including minors and
particularly when they are vulnerable on
the internet on the web it's a clear
principle I mean freedom of expression
absolutely but not if it is a form of
violence and slander that is why we need
to pay close attention to our social
networks we can't allow the haters to
have free
reign therefore this debate has a
purpose namely to reach out to council
asking the council to adopt a decision
unanimously as required by the treaty in
order to make sure that we have criminal
legislation in Europe in this field we
need it so much and also of course the
pasel Clause we've talked about the
reform of the treaties I think you know
we're looking forward to removing the
obstacles that prevent us from taking
decisions in Council because of this
unanimity
Rule and now I give the floor to faan
K mad Madame
President the commissioner DD rers
colleagues in recent years we've seen an
exponential increase of hate crimes and
hate speech this is dangerous for the
rule of law and democracy because the
too often they're in the service of an
extreme political IDE ideology their
representatives use these this hedge
speech to um Stoke
of anger and exacerbate fear so it's
necessary to extend the list of European
crimes so that we have a harmonized
definition of CRI hate crimes and hate
speech so we can identify it better and
fight it more
efficiently so I'd like to welcome the
commitment of the commissioner DDA
writers and my colleague
Mighty
pazo uh who who has been fighting
against this all her life and will never
give up I deplore as others do the
absence of a council representative in
this hemicycle we all know that we would
like the
council um is trying to stops blocking
this text for a strong Europe against
hate crime and hate speech thank you
thank you very much uh and I'll give the
floor to questioner marel
Kaya thank you Madame President dear
commissioner absent Council dear
colleagues roughly two years ago the
commission proposed the inclusion of
hate speech and hate crime in the list
of Euro crimes a necessary move to
establish ground rules for criminal
offenses and sanctions that would apply
across Europe you think that's an easy
one
right but no the member states decided
to impede on this
matter and be absent from this
debate it's painfully obvious that for
some governments protecting their
citizens from the rising tide of hate
crimes is about as important as
yesterday's news well scratch that it's
not even on their radar it's time to
ditch the delays drop the ideological
fights and focus on what matters
combating hate and protecting
victims this is a call to action this is
what is expected from you thank
you thank you very much
uhar the floor is
yours
thank you madam
president the term of um uh hate speech
is a new
word
if uh you you might think that there's
nothing but racism you're taking the
model from um the Soviet
Union in my country's uh uh legislation
there's a we've had a term of defamation
which we've managed with people can't
talk without uh uh hurting
somebody
and there have are also um an army of
civil servants who do very
little
and it's D dous to bring terms like this
into legislation it ends in
self-censorship and in the end in
dictatorship our next speaker is Philip
de man
please
all colleagues this is the first debate
we've had on so-called hate speech which
have to be tackled on
internet why is it the traditional
parties ass stubborn about such issues
they are clearly losing control over
public opinion people can read and say
whatever they want in
Internet this is something which the
regime can't accept the regime wants the
people to read only those things that
the regime authorized anything else
should be banned that seems to be the
opinion of most people in this house
anybody who is opposed to mass
immigration is a racist anybody who
opposes The Madness of around gender or
somebody who makes a joke about a fat
person or a thin person or a transgender
person or a black person or a Jew those
people are guilty of
crimes where whereas when it comes to
stupid F jokes about old white men
that's absolutely fine speaker on the
list
isi
must Mar thank you sir we see that there
is a rise in xenophobia in racist
phenomena uh things that all stem from
ethnocentrism patriarchy and cultural
racism
xenophobia hate and in general hate
against otherness is an element of this
new far right and we need to condemn it
in my country in Cy
lately we have seen two prgrams against
immigrants a few days
ago Kissa an NGO that works for
immigrant Rights was
firebombed we
need to make things clear concerning
hate
speech we need to fight these phenomena
and this has to be the first priority of
the European union we need to hurry with
legal measures and criteria in order to
Define hate crimes that will be the same
in all member states thank you very much
uh and now I give the floor to
Carlos
please thank you very much Madam
president commissioner dear colleagues
hate speech hate crime they are an
attack on human
dignity in a Europe of the 21st century
it has no place this type of discourse
is on the ascent fueled by populism and
also by social networks there can be no
gray areas there can be no hesitation
when we speak of Human Rights homophobia
kills intolerance based on hatred kills
if we want to effectively fight hate
speech and hate crime then we need to
nip the evil in the bud so to speak
where it starts we must stop these
mechanisms that allow this kind of
discourse to be disseminated and we need
action at the criminal law level if the
council is unable to reach a unanimous
position then it should be able to
decide by qualified majority hate crimes
are incompatible with the values of the
European Union democracy equality rule
of law and respect for human rights
thank you thank you uh and now I give
the floor to Lucas
kud do you know how much hate
costs the a price has been asked for by
the piss party the freedom of expression
is not the right to hate the
independence of the media is not a cart
blanch in in Poland we've had a very uh
very painful experience the peace party
has altered the broadcaster into a
government
Channel we we need to look at the way in
which the Pegasus documents have been
used uh you in the piss document are
responsible for this
the M Minister respect deserves respect
he's trying to um tidy the whole thing
up and put order in public broadcasting
I hope that the list of crimes will be
extended to hate crime and hate speech
and there's no place for hate speech
goes to Bata
k
thank you madam
president today we are talking about
hate speech however we have to start by
defining what this concept
means given the lack of a definition we
find ourselves facing a
situation where hate
speech could actually give rise to
severe criminal sanctions without a
definition we can't use this concept of
hate speech to be used to condemn other
Concepts in society freedom of
expression in society must not be
undermined by allowing people who have
different ideas about life different
ideologies to be
condemned so for
example the suggestion is that people
speaking out against Mass immigration
would be accused of hate speech so for
example if you were to like a
post uh for a post proving that mass
immigration is dangerous would that be
hate
speech I hope not we have to be
reasonable we have to avoid hate we have
to avoid uh harassment clearly I'm in
favor of a freedom of expression and but
I'm against publicly hounding or or
promoting
hate Madame President
I'm going to quote the uh list of
fundamental uh freedoms according to
article
21 any discrimination of political
thought or other opinions is banned in
the EU which is another sign of
hypocrisy here president of the
parliament SAS declared a cordon sanit
against our group
ID and he used lies but also hate when
uh he spoke about this which is why the
other political groups have decided not
to give us the representation in the
bodies of the parliament and on
committees citizens of the EU are
discriminated
against on the basis of their
nationality which is again a policy that
leads to Poverty you yourselves are
inight to
hatred we have to remove the causes of
hatred in reality you are looking for
excuses to suppress opinions that you
don't like you're talking about rights
but you're introducing censorship you
are punishing emotions that you in
yourself
inight uh and now I give the floor to
Martin colleagues today we enter the
terrible world of digital reality where
the loud calls of hate and editation are
heard social media platforms which which
accompany us every day are the stage for
an increase of online agitate agitation
our digital natives are the victims of
this threat the difficulty of hate
speech is that the dangers of in online
are emerg too late or remain hidden the
psychological uh damage um ends in the
loss of a young life and those guilty
are not
punished ha speech doesn't uh respect
borders and affects groups of minorities
as Parliament it's time to have a clear
position hate crime of any time must
have no space in our society it
under undermines not just the basic
values of the EU but the rights that we
stand for our demand is C clear the
commission must uh recognize hate speech
and hate crime as an European crime we
must take clear
legal steps so that we can um avoid uh
online hate and make sure that the those
responsible are brought to Justice the
floor to Karina
olon
om if half the population don't express
their opinion on social media because
they're scared of being attacked being
hated what does that mean for our
democratic societ societies if nobody or
many don't feel that they can
participate women decide to remain
silent young women don't go into
politics uh women's rights activists are
facing death threats the hatred against
women is organized by nationalists by
extremists and when women call out this
problem they're told that they should
take a break from the internet that's
the same kind of advice that's given to
women if their attire is not correct
they should avoid dressing in this way
in order to not encourage this type of
attack we as politicians have a
responsibility to Bear when it comes to
legislating but also when it comes to
setting aside resources to counter
hatred and we ourselves need to
contribute to a healthy debating climate
not one marked by
hatred thank you very much uh our next
speaker is Andre
slavov
thank you Madame President this is an
attempt to incriminate personal opinion
of people who do not actually agree with
the bolik ideology of the powerful
certain identities are protected here
and each criticism of them is viewed as
hatred and fascism because it's easier
to jail our
opponents why do we talk about hate
speech only when it targets minorities
gay people and so on or else there is no
hate of heterosexual people or
Christians this issue does not concern
90% of the European
citizens they may included care about
honesty Integrity compassion and
sympathy political affiliation sexual
orientation ethnic origin are private
matters this claim has not been put
forward by citizens by but by
politicians the European Community needs
Justice and fairness not perks for
minorities thank you very much
indeed next speaker is G Maya
P thank you madam
president the majority of the examples
which we've heard cited as covering hate
speech today are actually covering
something else the vast majority of
penal codes in Europe actually cover all
of these acts and they're currently
subject to fines to sanctions This is
highly sensitive and controversial isue
we're talking about I simply don't
believe you when people say that this
legislation would not be
used to uh silence or muzzle those who
Express opinions you don't like so let's
take the example of
Hungary somebody from
Hungary uh who is not popular with the
groups of the left here and supported by
the EP and muscle our colleague barley
from the snd said this very clearly
beforehand she referred specifically as
the to the afd condemning them I hope
what she said Madam president will be
examined very carefully in the minutes
to see whether that damages the Dignity
of this
house I would prefer to see the European
Parliament devoting more energy to
efforts to elucidate the corruption
candles which snd governments have been
involved in our next speaker uh is
sunana laak
please thank you Madame President dear
colleagues um in the rising
globalization it is definit we
definitely need to strengthen uh legal
Frameworks
um uh prosecution is needed given that
there is a rise of intolerance I would
like to say a few words about uh online
uh hate speech and this is uh very often
and introduction uh to violence there
such channels are fertile ground and
have a strong multi multiplying effect
just uh remember Nicole Fox we spoke
about her case in the European
Parliament uh peer
violence and exposure to uh violence is
a problem a study has shown that almost
50% of children have been exposed to
violence online this is not an issue on
restricting the freedom of speech this
is
uh this is the right for all citizens to
live in Freedom and we should uh we I
think uh we should make a difference
here our next speaker is Sirus andura
please Pua Dyke monster it all
starts with one word but it sadly ends
with a knife a fist and in certain cases
a gun this report should be a wakeup
call for ministers to finally make hate
speech and hate crime a European Union
crime ministers were very quickly some
months ago to add some other crimes in
this list but why not these you see the
commission is ready the European
Parliament is ready Civil Society is
ready our citizens are ready but the
council is the only missing one always
missing when there is a need to deliver
protection of basic human rights and
even in this debate where is the council
the presidency is not here and not even
one representative of one member state
in this chamber on this very important
topic which they have blogged for a
number of months and years now can
ministers continue to turn a blind eye
on the rise of hate speech all around
Europe targeting in particular women the
lgbtiq community refugees migrants and
opposing one Community against another
this is unacceptable radicalization of
farri right and conservative narratives
es especially anonymously online must be
stopped by all means thank you thank you
uh I give the floor to
Jill
please sh colleague colleagues the
commission and the majority in the
parliament proposing including hate
speech in the list of European
crimes under article um 83 and the
treaties I'm against this for two
reasons first of all the no notion of
hate speech is so vague and subjective
that it opens the gate to censure and
political persecution the
report
is cites xenop xenophobic speech and
what they're proposing
is uh
is
um
supporting migration and is against
Democratic life secondly the Comm
commission proposal is against the
respect of the the French Constitution
because it takes the up the words of the
Avia War
law um which is UN undermined of freedom
of expression the the national
Constitution is superior to all treaties
including EU treaties which has been U
pointed out by the Constitutional Court
in November 20 2004 the in EU
institutions can't uh impose on France
any law which is stand
constitutional uh our next speaker is
yila Novak
please honorable chair honorable
commissioner man where are you going
where are you headed when it comes to
humanity and values that are the
cornerstones of our democracy humanity
and our civilization where is it headed
hate speech and hate crime rep represent
a direct attack on human Integrity uh
and uh Freedom they endanger the basic
values of the EU particularly in the
light of growing extremism and the
growing impact of social media is it
even possible or likely that some people
in Democratic societies beat up an
elder uh person who is completely
helpless uh film that and post it on
social media for other people to like uh
our uh democracy requires us to respond
both as legislators as well as as a
society R
seats for presid
in Madame President honorable colleagues
hate speech hate crime crime
unfortunately it's becoming a really
important societal problem and it's a
threat to our states governed by the
rule of law young people in particular
need to be protected against all these
forms of hatred we don't need categories
here but we need to make sure that the
internet is not some kind of free space
to express hatred of any sort also
unfortunately in the meantime we're
experiencing the very same phenomenon on
our streets it's part of our daily lives
um also for instance religious belonging
Jewish citizens in particular have been
attacked under the same
principle also somebody might be
attacked because they are living with a
disability again hate speech and hate
crime cannot be allowed to spread in
this way there are a number of things we
can do first of all we should have
minimum standards in the European Union
that's the first step and ladies and
gentlemen I truly deplore the fact that
the council has made zero progress on on
this over the course of the last two
years it's time for Action thank you
very much uh and I give the floor to M
sha thank you uh commissioner
colleagues it has been two years since
the uh commission communication on the
expansion of uh the list of European uh
crimes on uh uh to hate speech and hate
crime but the council hasn't uh
responded
while uh hate speech and hate crime is
uh becoming more and more frequent
especially uh in social networks I
believe uh there is no time to waste I
believe we don't need to change a man
the manner of voting in the council that
uh a majority of the council will uh
support a reasonable solution to my
colleagues on the right I would like to
say that the protection of human dignity
is a basic conservative principle and I
believe that uh uh specification of a
crime that goes against human dignity is
something conservative uh members of
parliament should support what has
started in Ireland with the adoption of
uh a law against cyber crime uh I hope
will be uh continued on the um uh
European level especially
protecting children against cyber crime
and that's why the commission should not
stop with its initiative procedure and I
start with Susana
chardi freedom of thought is one of the
foundations of the Western World free
thinkers scientists philosophers are the
people who built the pillars of Freedom
here in Europe the pillars of our
well-being at the same time we now have
a a left bureaucracy who wants to drive
us back to the Dark
Ages I agree that freedom of thought
must be subject to certain limits of
course however do you know that Italy
has decriminalized the crime of uh
insulting
people however it's the left here who
are now trying to preach to us from
their pull pit we agree that hate uh
social jealousy or political resentment
can often be negative sentiments last
week a woman committed suicide following
a hate speech which was triggered off by
influences who referring to the
left so I strike a note of caution for
the
left stop trying to adopt these laws
which are simply designed to damage your
political adversaries particularly when
you're actually doing the opposite in
reality and now I give the floor to Mick
Wallace
president the minister for justice in
Ireland published a hate crime bill in
2022 if this was already law the arish
Prime Minister our tiok could well be
facing a charge of grossly trivializing
or denying genocide in relation to sou
Africa's case against Israel the Irish
leader said genocide is defined as the
deliberate attempt to destroy an entire
nation or entire race or to do so in
large part at no point does the genocide
convention used the phrase in large part
the convention says in whole or in part
in large part suggests it is necessary
to intend to destroy a sizable majority
of a group for the threshold of genocide
to be reached the t-shock also asked if
the Hamas attack on October 7th was not
also a genocide he questioned the
indisputable fact that Israel is
committing genocide while offering as an
alternative an utterly bizarre example
for which there is no case before any
International Court the Irish leader has
undermined the scope of the genocide
convention and tralized Irish Israeli
genocide he does not speak for the
people of
Ireland uh with these words our speakers
list is closed and I invite the
commissioner to to hold his final speech
please thank you Madame President
honorable members the frightening
increase in hate speech online in recent
months and weeks as as many speakers
have said uh calls
for a decisive response obviously
freedom of thought must be encouraged
respect and and tolerance are founding
values of the European Union hate is a
threat to the functioning of our
democracy because it can discourage
citizens or sometimes journalists or
politicians from participating actively
in the democratic
debate we must use a full panoply of
tools public policies legislation and we
must ensure that all stakeholders be
involved the European Union institutions
National authorities civil society and
online
Platforms in this context the commission
underlines the need to quickly adopt the
proposal for decision from the
council suggesting that we extend the
list of Euro crimes to hate speech and
crime I would like to thank the
parliament for its support on this file
I would like to thank you for all the
points which have been raised in today's
debate thank you thank you very much uh
commissioner and uh theor
M you have of course the final
word thank you so much Madame President
and thank you commissioner as well thank
you for your
words All That Remains for me to do is
to thank my colleagues for their
contributions to this uh debate the
great majority of you who took part in
this debate I think that it's shown that
the broad majority of this house is
clear on this we are political operators
political agents and we carry enormous
respon responsibility in terms of the
ecosystem of public opinion we really
could set a good example or a bad
example to the rest of our citizenship
you know what it means to have pluralism
what it means to exercise freedom of
conscience of expression so we need to
be careful be mindful of that you know
think of what we do what we say because
otherwise we could actually drift into
this sphere of hatred and
hostility that said I think most of you
really have taken the floor to show that
you want to collectively work against
the most dangerous manifestations of
this type of dis course that can
actually lead to the very serious crime
of hate speech I very much hope that
tomorrow the parliament in its majority
will also view it that way I would like
to I would like to thank in particular
magdalina because you've been an example
in terms of how we can actually um deal
with this issue you know suffering the
consequences of the most intolerable
types of uh hate
speech victimization that is really
really really awful and complicated to
resolve so that is precisely why we need
to fight this phenomenon and we deploy
the fact that council is not in the
chamber this afternoon also I would urge
us all to look at things as they are not
with the preconceived idea you know
individuals who are being assassinated
even in Spain uh young members of the
Roma Community uh in other countries um
children you know maybe a black child
being attacked because he is black just
2 years old 48 Hours of torture
inflicted Upon A person who was uh
suffering from a mental disability uh
you know in Spain awful awful hate
crimes or a a persant woman who had uh
converted to Christianity again an
attack this time in France or gays young
gay people being Attack Just for being
gay in a bar in Slovakia these are hate
crimes colleagues let's be clear on that
thank
you thank you uh very much and with
these words uh the debate is closed the
vote will be held tomorrow we're coming
to the next item on the agenda which is
the report of Karina Bali situation of
fundamental rights in the European Union
in 2022 and
please thank you very much Madam
president commissioner the European
Union